in our morning rounds medical news with
more States moving towards legalizing
marijuana for recreational and medical
use there are still unanswered questions
about safety not only for our health but
also for drivers and passengers on our
roadways CBS News chief medical
correspondent Dr John lauk took a closer
look at the most advanced driving
simulator in the world at the University
of Iowa the study of the effects of
driving under the influence of cannabis
has been in high gear it looks like a
spaceship and there's an entire car
inside Dr Marilyn westis has been
studying cannabis for 20 years the
ability to take information in evaluate
it make decisions and initiate them
greatly affected by cannabis she put me
in the driver's seat when we visited the
lab for 60 minutes it's changing the
car's going away I feel the rumbling in
my seat I'm looking in the side view
mirror wow
so what a fabulous resource this is for
us to safely evaluate the effects of
drugs the simulator presents real life
driving experiences designed to test and
impair drivers reactions but if I were
stoned and somebody suddenly ran out um
I might have a slower reaction time you
might have slow you definitely would
have a slower reaction and a harder time
deciding what you should do right now
there is no reliable road side test to
know for sure if a driver is impaired by
cannabis so marijuana has a number of
important effects one of the things that
it affects is the ability to stay within
your lane the weaving that occurs okay
it also has a tremendous effect on your
speed at low doses it will reduce your
speed because the marijuana driver tends
to think they might be impaired so they
try to compensate
by going slower now that can be very
dangerous these dangers are at the heart
of a recent study which found more than
half of Michigan resident surveyed who
use medical cannabis for chronic pain
admitted to driving while a little high
one in five admitted to driving while
very high study author Aon Bonar says
unlike alcohol there's currently no
legal limit for pot there's so many
different types of marijuana products
that have a different amount of THC in
them and we don't yet know enough about
how we're processing and metabolizing
those products to say well you can have
this much of a gummy or you can have
this many hits of a vape and then be
safe that's a concern for law
enforcement there are 2.1 million
medical marijuana users across the 33
states where medical cannabis is legal
those States vary in the amount of
psychoactive component allowed people
aren't even being counseled about what's
legal and what's not legal to do if if
you're prescribed cannabis in a state
neurologist Dr Orin divinsky of NYU
landone Health conducted the trials that
led to the first FDA approved cannabis
medication a drug for epilepsy has the
use of medical marijuana and the
legislation of it gotten ahead of the
science absolutely essentially
politicians have voted that this should
be a legal medical therapy and we don't
have data from rigorous scientific
studies to Define what the safety is for
CBS This Morning sat today Dr John
leuk fascinating yeah but when I see
this I see another argument for
driverless cars certainly it's so
interesting too though anything
surrounding marijuana it's still a
schedule one narcotic and that makes any
of the research more difficult because
of the accessibility of it whether it's
testing that drug companies want to do
or somebody using it in a different form
or something like this too you as you
asked in the middle of this what's a
little high exactly yeah you think they
would have figured all of this out
before they passed the laws so any
questions
guess